want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation
from jack ma enjoy
this world today is full of challenges
and opportunities
two thousand years ago full of
challenges
and opportunities and i'm sure two
thousand years later
full of challenges and opportunities is
always
it depends on how you look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people always say
there's no opportunity
i complained a lot when i was young
because i think bill gates took all the
opportunities for the microsoft
steve jobs all these guys there's no job
there's no great big stuff left
for us but i think
opportunity always lies in the
challenges
always lies in the complaints if you can
solve the challenge
you have to you you will be successful
the big challenge you solve
the big problem of the the big
opportunity you have
it's a great experience to be an
entrepreneur
life is so cool when you become
entrepreneur
in my life the day
i never write a book for myself i think
those people write books are getting too
old
my life's just the beginning the day
when i want to write i want to write a
book alibaba 1001 mistakes
and i want to tell my kids how many
tough days i have gone through
how many miss silly mistakes i've made
and this is the best experience this is
because it's easy to be good but it's
tough to be bad
in the first five years steve in my
company
i always giving the case studies
of failure companies to every of my
people today the thing i want to share
more with the young entrepreneurs is
how many mistakes we made how many
companies bankrupted
why they bankrupted i never teach like
mba teach people
how they succeed how that one success
when you
when young people learn that too much
they think they can easily succeed
going to business is like going to
battlefield
only those people survive win and you
know
how to avoid stupid action so when you
learn the mistakes
that's the failures cases not to avoid
mistakes
but when you know when you meet these
mistakes you know
how to face it how to solve it how to
challenge it
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
created a special
free program called 254 because the sign
says that it takes up to 254 days of
consecutive action to build a habit
so what i'm going to do is send you an
unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below it's so
difficult to be a small business owner
in china
it took me five months to borrow 500
the people who do the model should
believe in the model and i believe what
i do
we have a lot of heroes but china movies
heroes always dead the american
movie hero never die if all the heroes
die
who want to be the hero well trust is
the
most important thing as we discussed
this a few minutes ago
if people give me when i had no money
because when alibaba started
18 founders in my apartment i told
everybody say
put you all your money savings on the
table leaving
the money for for 10 months food
and room you know rent what's that
the money you have put on the table i
want to gather the money and nobody
should borrow the money from parents
nobody should borrow money from friends
because i don't want to make your
parents and friends bankrupt
because doing alibaba so 18 people we
gathered
50 000 u.s dollars we studied alibaba in
my apartment
and those people actually
none of us have money but if if somebody
say i give you one million u.s dollars
and i give you trust which one i would
choose
i choose those people who give me the
trust
because it's the trust that make make
us be united it's the
i think 18 founders they trust me
because they trust me i have to be very
loyalty
to them and loyal to the mission that uh
that we have i think a lot of
entrepreneurship know that
i hate people work for me i want people
work for the mission that we agreed
together
because you don't want people work for
me because people like me
when i look when i look further this
guy's a handsome wayne get closer he's
so ugly
everybody in the world the same you
should not get closer
further is good so you think a jack is
great but you know if you get closer
not necessarily i would be angry i will
happy i'm happy
i got but when people trusting
you that's the most valuable things
i think later when we got our event
venture capitalists invested us
the thing they noticed is that because
my team trust me and i trust
my teams if you don't want to give up
everything
you will get nothing a lot of business
people
they never learn to focus if your
startup learn to be focused on one thing
right because learn to be focused just
like there are nine rabbits on the
ground
if you want to catch the rabbit don't
change the rabbit
change yourself if you want to catch
this one finally you got nothing
so for nine rabbits don't change the
rabbit
change yourself to catch that rabbit
until you got it
a great entrepreneurs should not have a
money if you have a money in your mind
this is us dollars this is iron b and
you're talking like english pounds
nobody will work with like
if you have a good dream if you have a
plan
to making things making progress things
were happening
and i changed my mind to this morning
just half an hour there
i would do more things in africa and the
only thing i want to do is not to sell
products here and i will enable you to
sell your dreams all over the world in
africa
supporting entrepreneurs is always my my
dream
because i know how tough it is to be an
entrepreneur it is difficult
i never cry i said i only make my
competitors cry
because if i cry i probably die a
hundred times
because we have to encourage
our team and i say making sure that we
that we can survive tomorrow as i said
before i answer questions i want to say
this is my belief
and this is what i tell every day to
myself today
is difficult tomorrow is much more
difficult
but the day of tomorrow is beautiful
most people die tomorrow evening
even today as my size for our company's
size
i still believe today is very difficult
i have more problems than anybody here
can imagine
you say ah now you are big you make
billions of dollars
every you know quarter i have
much more problems than you have much
more headache than you have
very very important is that
trust the young people i trust the more
young
i trust young people more than trusted
senior people successful people
there is no expert there is no expert
of a future there is only expert of
yesterday
we are entering into the century in the
world that is so new
working with the young people you're
talking about the future
working with most of the success people
they only talk about yesterday and when
talking to those people always talk
about yesterday you don't have the
future
that's what we think today the 18
founders of alibaba
a lot of people think they are legendary
something wow you all ibaba founders you
must be
super good at honestly most of us cannot
find
jobs early days we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a you know a
great university
um but the thing is that we are ready to
learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we learn with improve
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about
that you will be vp vice president right
you will always be a tiny manager in
your life
because if we're successful people will
hide they will be smarter than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
you will be happy because this is the
mission that we have
so i will say there's no best
people in the world that is suit ready
for you the best of people is always
you you find the right people working
together
training him developing him and he
training you
then you have a chance to build a team
well when i went back to china in 1995
with an
idea of the internet was very strange
china was not connected to the internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is
internet nobody say ah this thing never
work this thing never exists
um because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to
when i go to the china red company
registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo
hope internet company
the guy looked at me saying this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's
no word called the internet why you want
a registered company called the internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but it i
in 1995 in
later august china was connected the
internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to prove i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we they just try to take the picture
i i
die from houngsu to shanghai shanghai to
america to connect the internet
it took us three hours and a half to
download the first
front of the page at that time there is
no netscape called the mosaic
oh so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my
journalists friends to stay and wait
because to prove that i'm not telling a
lie
as entrepreneur we never complain
we make other people complain
we make our competitors complain we
never cry
because if christ can solve the problems
guess what no problem we make
competitors cry we make those people
who do not believe our dreams cry i
think people worry about
jobs today we think people worry about
artificial intelligence
well don't worry too much about that
people are improving and people working
by the security
alibaba got in the past of five years
every day we got a 300 million attacks
per day but we think it's opportunity
let's learn it let's learn how to do it
solve the problems and then in the
future when we got experience
share with the others that's the whole
thing so
i want to get encouraging everybody look
at the future
we cannot avoid it we have to embrace it
we have to live it
think about the future and there are a
lot of things my grandfather will never
be surprised we will be so surprised
that today
human being have so many jobs can be
created you have a lot of smart people
but you say there's a difference between
smart and wise tell us about that yeah
the difference between smart people know
what they want
and why people know what they don't want
so i have a lot of smart people it's
difficult to deal with smart people
very difficult it's easy to deal with
stupid people you know they follow they
go to toilet they go to restaurant
together
but smart people it's all different but
what we need
a company is not it's not a farm
my company is a zoo we have
all kinds of animals people talk
people never talk people work hard
people never work i mean these are
this is this is amazing ecosystem of the
company that make the company
very very powerful and colorful i feel
happy that
and a leader is not the proof you are
smarter than the others
a leader's job is to making sure
everybody giving their smart ideas out
you listen to them and sometimes
you make a stupid decision because you
have to balance
you have to believe in the future it's
not smart to people win
it's the wise people win and for the
future
so this is what i believe we need more
wise people
our leaders smart machine will be
always smarter than you are a machine
can never be wiser smart people using
brain
wise people using heart
machines don't have heart machines only
have chips
so this is what i think human beings
should always
learn to be wise to say
no to know what you don't want
that's that's my view i like the people
who never give
up and i've been proved this for so many
years
i've seen so many great leaders in the
world in
many many fields those people are always
optimistic they don't complain ah
you know because of this because that no
they
they think they completely complain ah i
was not that smart i did not think about
that clearly so i have to
need to change so if you find the people
who always complain the others because
you know success
don't hide him don't work
our first ipo years year 2007 when
alibaba
appealed in hong kong year 2007
we had a lot of millionaires in the
company
and i asked my friend my colleagues are
like we have like a 300 people
become millionaires and i ask them hey
now tell me
you become millionaires because you are
smarter than the others
people say no no no no no we even cannot
find jobs
because you're hard working yes we were
have we we find
more people hard working than us but
they do not succeed
one of why they're not smart all the
smart people at that time
they went to microsoft and ibm
and head hunting companies came to
headhunt all the best guy from us
and we are the people nobody come to
head on us
we have no place to go we believe in
ourselves
we believe our dream we work together
so i say we are the people because
nobody wants us
i am the person over 30 companies don't
want to meet
right so we are the people get used to
be rejected
we are the people get used to be say no
from the other people
why people should help you people help
you that is unusual people do not
help you that is very common
you should work to earn to be helped
kfc has refused to hire you
so uh with all these uh
know how at the end of the day what has
been the driver which
has made you who you are
yeah i wish people can say yes to me but
if they say yes i have no choice i have
to accept it
and of course you're not happy when
people say no
have a good sleep wake up try it again
it's always my fault not the other
people's part why you can convince
people
if you cannot prove it but the thing is
that
very important there are two group of
people you have to convincing
first group people your team they
believe in you
they trust in you and they believe the
things we agreed together
and second is uh your customers
they really love your products and
investors it's okay when you do business
my rule is
never be feared never worry about
competition never worry about um
you know the the pressures
if you worry about the pressure you will
worry about a competition if you're
worried about this
don't do don't be a businessman and
today the good thing is the whole world
worries everywhere people worry about
data
people worry about privacy people worry
about security
people worry about anything
that normally is that means great
opportunity comes
because you know you cannot stop this
the internet time is coming
mobile time is coming back data is
coming you cannot stop
not worry with the only thing is you
embrace you change yourself
and start to do it and is there any
system
no if you have a system you never worry
nobody has a system ask your president
he doesn't have a system
right if you're a human being you
worries your doubts
but the only difference without you when
you fix the problem you
change yourself you fight again tomorrow
the future has no
experts
right we entrepreneurs
someday we are the experts
right so this is what i think and
when you
where entrepreneurs get used to
failure today say alibaba you
succeed well our company won't last 102
years
why 102 years because every target
every goal we give to our team should be
very accurate
we were born in 1999 last century we had
one year we want to spend 100 years and
plus
one year one or two across three
centuries
so very accurate we never see we are
successful because we are only 19 years
old there is 83 years to go
so we will never see we are successful
we just survived
19 years we are lucky but
in the past 19 years we have made
thousands of mistakes
as an entrepreneur don't learn from
other people how they succeed
learn from how these people fail
because a lot of mba schools they teach
you success
successful case studies when you read
too many successful you think you can be
successful no
[Applause]
there are a lot of things that you don't
know
because you know some business school
came to alibaba write case studies
they say i know this is alibaba and as
you know this is not alibaba they wanted
me to sign
after one week study they say this is
case study alibaba ace no this
is not me they say jack you don't know
you
and that's all right i signed and
next to five years every year there is a
case study
in qinghua university i was invited
sitting at the back listen to the mba
schools
talk learning about our case study and
they always put a competitor
competitor in alibaba who will succeed
for five years
all they always agree alibaba will die
the competitor will win
but five years all the competitors died
so how can you learn from the case study
like that
learn from the mistakes because the
mistake most of the companies i
i talked to entrepreneurs most of the
mistakes
they made are the same most of the
success
reasons you don't know the different
reasons
so when you learn from the mistakes not
because you want to avoid the mistakes
because
when you see the mistakes when you have
this kind of problems
you know how to face it an entrepreneur
have a strong heart
the difficulties mistakes the troubles
the failures
but should it be a warm and soft heart
to your colleagues
and to the customers i came here to
share with you the
entrepreneur's spirit in the dreams
this is what i learned from the other
part of the world i learned from the
american dreams
i learned from many other startups in
the whole world
that the stream the how they do it i
think the very important
is that making sure your dream can be
realized
making sure your dream makes steps by
step
every week every month and making sure
that
your employees believe in making sure
your customers are happy
because your if your customer happy your
employees are happy
the shareholder will be happy do not try
to spend a lot of time with your
shareholders
spend enough time with your customers
spend enough time with your employees
and even do not spend a lot of time with
the competitors
because you are we are all so early
stage
the best way to compete to fight against
your competitor
is your customers it's your colleagues
i know nothing about technology i know
nothing but marketing i know nothing
about the legal
or all the stuff what do you know i
don't know about people
i know people i was trained to be a
teacher
as a teacher you want your students
better than you are
you want you want your best product is
your students
you want this student to be a lawyer
that's to visit a banker that's to be
the entrepreneur that is a is a
mayor you don't want don't want this
bankrupt that in the jail that is in
trouble
so you always want people better and
then you have to listen to them you want
to see that
and then make the all the things to
making sure that you can empower them
you can make them cheap teamwork you can
then collaborate
so this is how we do and i find the more
you care about your team
the team will care about you and the
team will care about their customers
so i talk to all of my people early days
don't make me happy
don't love me make your customer happy
make your customer love you and i will
love you any minute
that is very simple so everything we do
as a founder
make your customer happy gather your
team make your team happy
and you will be happy we faced a lot of
challenges
but i'm sure alibaba is going to face
more challenges
we worry every day when i was young
when company was young we thought well
what if when alibaba
become that big my life would be easier
then now the companies that the bigger
the company the more problems i have
so why you are still small company
enjoy it you will never experience
the happiness of operating a small
company
any life we're going to be too big you
have so much headaches
so many things happening and people say
jack
you know there are a lot of books about
you but there's none of the books i
write myself
if there's one book i want to write in
the future it's called alibaba
1001 mistakes we made
so many mistakes we had so many troubles
believing or not china
build up e-commerce company build up
a internet related company
no internet connection at that time
no v no no credit cards
no delivery system it's
so we make we meet problems all the time
it's not easy but we tell ourselves
we will be successful until we make 10
000 mistakes
we'll be successful if we survive
in any crisis so when crisis came
we know it's a challenge everybody
start to be united we solve the
challenge
then we complete each other before
we solve the problem of the crisis we
should not complain
so i have a problem in
in hr i have a problem in financing i
have a problem in technology i have a
problem everywhere
tell me so that's why i i become a
mentor
in entrepreneurs a program in china
people a lot of entrepreneurs have
crashing when i listen to their
questions
oh my god i have this problem too so
i would say we have gone through almost
almost
nine more than 90 percent of the
problems
that any entrepreneur 90 of the problems
that any entrepreneurs have met this is
what we feel
proud at the end of the day i'm going to
tell my kids my grandchildren
it's not the thing we feel proud we
we made alibaba it's so many mistakes
that we overcome so many challenges
we experienced that make me feel proud
life
is about experience so when you become
entrepreneur
don't worry about the competitors don't
worry about the mistakes
don't worry about the challenges go
through it
that's the great fun part of your
business
of your experience and then you got a
courage
you got a wisdom you got a team follow
you when i started alibaba 1999
i want to share some of things at first
we believe in the future
and i believe internet can empower a lot
of people it's not
jack ma helped so many people
it's the entrepreneurships the spirit
of creating the spirit
of constructive advice and disease
and very also very very important
is that we believe technology will help
people
for a better future so
we try to be creative we try to solve
problems
when people complain we don't complain
we think about complaining of the other
people is always a great opportunity
if we can solve the complaining and then
we have the solutions
then we have the future so we do alibaba
because we believe in there's so many
small businesses don't know
when and how where they can sell the
products so we help them to promote
their products
we have the payment because no banks at
that time
love to help small business and they
don't know how to help a small business
we know if we don't have a payment our
e-commerce is just the talk
on the line it's just the chat online
so we have this payment and then we find
if we cannot help people to deliver
efficiently and quickly
then there will be no way so we build up
the
the uh the logistics system and then we
find a lot of companies don't know have
the technology
especially small business they don't
know how to use the internet
the internet service is too expensive
them so we say all right
let's build up the cloud computing so
every small business
can using cloud computing internet
technology cheaply and efficiently
so it's all about solving problems so i
think
this is what we did in the past 20 years
we always think about
what we can do to solve this social
problems
instead of complaining that's that's the
journey
and i'm having great fun when you really
help people when you see
millions of people change their lives
because
the efforts that we work together who's
your most dangerous competitor
is it amazon or is it 10 cent
well people always think compare us with
amazon is a great company i respect i've
been seeing them
from a tiny to that big and i think they
will continue to grow
but we are different we the amazon is an
e-commerce company
we are not e-commerce company we
enable other people to do e-commerce we
want to make sure
everybody can be amazon so are you
saying tencent is the greater
oh of course they're a great company and
you know
it's it's not easy to be
that size within only such less than 20
years
so innovative and so creative
and so different on social technology
and they're based
in in dungeon and they're almost
everywhere in china
but respect of course we compete but
compete does not mean i have to hate
them
don't hate your competitors
respect your competitors learn from him
but you know paulie and i we've been
doing the
charity together the nature conservancy
and protected the
but we compete each other but when we
compete each other
we should respect each other i respect
him i respect him
in the past 18 years when i do internet
in china we got a criticism
every day you know something where you
believe it a lot of people criticize it
but if you really believe continue to do
it improve it
we are rejected by more than 30 venture
capitalists
but we are very optimistic we believe in
the future
we believe in internet and we believe
that if we do not succeed somebody will
when i started my business 1995
it was very difficult i had an idea
i invited 24 of my friends my apartment
because that year i went to seattle
first time
my first trip to the usa in seattle i
discovered
internet and i think this thing in the
future may change the world
tell me about the encounter with the
internet when you first saw it yeah i
went to the
seattle and a friend of mine he had a
small office with like a four or five
computers
i never touched computer in my life
before because computer was so expensive
to me
and so complicated but my friend said
this is internet just to type in
whatever word
you want to type it's a no no too
expensive i don't know which one to do
even now i don't know how a computer
works
they said jack it's not a bomb just the
type or whatever so the first
word i typed in was a beer b-e-i beer i
don't drink
i don't know why i'm type of beer i
found american beer german beer japanese
beer no china so i typed the word
china there's no information about
china so i say what if we can make some
china information
on the internet let people know about
china
so that was the idea so i came back to
china
and say i want to resign from my school
you're a teacher i was a teacher i've
been teaching in the
university for six years so i said
i want to do it i invite 24 of my
friends to my apartment
after two hours of explaining what i'm
going to do
internet and 23 of them say forget it
he said this thing never worked because
there's no such thing called
internet in the world you know nothing
about a computer
so why you want to do this and um
only one people he said jack
if you want to try it just to try it but
if it's something wrong just come back
and after whole night thinking i say i
still want to do it
because most of the people they have a
fancy ideas in the evening but in the
date
when they wake up in the evening or in
the morning they go back to do the same
job
we have to do something different so
from there
i started my business borrowing 2000 us
dollars from my
relatives and friends well that was my
trip
i call myself like a blind man
riding on the back of blind tigers
and those people who are expert of
riding horses they all fall
down and i'm still surviving one of the
things i want to share with the values
the six values among the two values very
unique in alibaba which i think the
whole world should
think about we put custom number one
in price number two shareholder number
three most
companies in wall street they put the
shareholder number one
i said each customer
is the most important if you serve them
well they pay you the money
and the second important is colleagues
why the college get together because
they want to serve the customers
if they do not cost serve the customers
why we get it together
right so if the customer happy in price
happy the
shareholders will be happy as
entrepreneur i think most of the
projects i heard there
is about platform you are guys are
building my platform
you know the essence of building a
platform a lot of people in china want
to
build up a platform you the
the difference between build a company a
bit of a platform
is a platform is to enable others
make other people happy a company is to
make yourself happy
there's a difference between 20th
century and 21st century
if you 21st century if you want to be
successful
making sure your employees are
successful
making sure your customers are
successful because of using your
services
if you can make your customers
successful
in price successful your platform will
be successful
this is the essence and remember that
empower others you're empowering
yourself
and you're empowering your platform i
think i'm so proud
that we have so many smart people in
this company and also
so proud in the past 20 years
we make these smart people learn how to
be a human
how to care most smart people want to
win
and we want to make smart people learn
how to
live like a human how to care others
how to do things for the others and when
they learn that
when smart people learn how to care
others
[Music]
how to care future how to be a human
then the company becomes warm smooth
and soft power otherwise you
have a group of cancers if you want to
have a smart people work for you
the smart people need to be managed by
culture not by rules and laws
so in our company we spend
most of the time about the culture
and the base of the culture is the trust
so this is this is what we believe
leadership
is not only about inspiring leadership
is those people who join your company
you have to create value for him you
have to making sure
in three years he will be different
not because his job is different because
if the people not different
the products will never be different
i told many people when they joined
alibaba
i say guys i don't know fortunate or
unfortunate to join alibaba
we work much longer than the others
much harder we had more problems than
most of the companies
if you can survive in alibaba you can
survive at any company in the world
because life is tough we never promise
you will be rich you'll be successful
you will probably promote it but we will
promise you
you will be a problem you have a wrong
you make mistake you have a terrible
boss
we all promised so you set the
expectation
but have a good vision so that is the
way we manage
the company and i think
when you hide good people the good
people
believe the vision they will go so when
i visiting the company
whether it's a good ceo or not i do not
listen to the ceo
i listen to his people if the people
believe the vision
all the people believe this guy if the
people believe the vision
if the people believe this guy this
company has hope
a good a good entrepreneur
can always tell good stories i don't
need to listen story from you guys
i can tell your people right if your
people
any young people in your company he can
tell me the vision
he can tell me what they're doing that
is a good company
that's leadership leadership making sure
everybody when they sleep
when they drink when they talk when they
go to toilet they talk your vision
and they believe it last century the
bigger the better
this century the good the better do the
business
not because the size it's not necessary
the big size you are the more profit you
are you really believe that
i believe it's a different business you
know we got a fortune 500 companies
you you judge because of the size how
many of them are really happy
how many of them profit no small
companies
they're very profitable they're very
happy they can spend time with the wife
and the husband and kids traveling
around
and that's the life don tried to be the
best
be the first be the first to change
be the first to take the challenge
be the first one to overcome the
difficulties
because the best person there's only one
olympic
champion i don't think i'm lucky enough
to be that
but i can always try the new things and
don't give up
i believe it because you you are so
unique everybody is
unique be yourself is always the key and
also i am encouraging all the
entrepreneurs
if you want to start a business don't
think you will be successful next month
or next year think about at least the
five years
because if something can be successful
next month
why you you have a rich father you don't
have to be startup
right and by the way don't be
discouraged
because you have a poor diploma or
you know graduate from a poor university
or low education don't worry about that
if you graduate from mit harvard you
will never be entrepreneur
right they can only be the white collar
guys
so as an entrepreneur you should have
this what is the strategy for
entrepreneurs
strategy is time 10 years you compete
with the other people
the vision the world will be there will
be there
what kind of customers they need how we
can build up if you
prepare for five years and 10 years if
you have a good team
and always do before the government do
if you're waiting for government you
have no chance
right when governments say there is
opportunity there go that direction
because we'll be too crowded there if
jackman can be successful
succeed 80 percent of the young people
can be successful
we don't have money we don't have a
relationship
i don't have a powerful rich father even
though we don't have a rich father or
uncle
that can sponsor us everything we do
is the 18 funders we believe the future
we make progress even among the 18
founders
we only have three engineers among the
three engineers
only one of them had a three years
experience at university
static computer the other two
they are like amateur computer they when
they open it they don't know how to fix
it
[Music]
start from there to today we have 25
000 engineers in our company
and nobody come to buy and sell
for the first two weeks terrible we
build an e-commerce company
nobody comes to sell so we have to list
our own products on there
wait for two weeks nobody come to buy so
we have to buy ourselves
and then the first first month
some people come to sell things on our
site we buy everything so we buy a whole
house of rubbish
for the whole month we started nobody
believed
e-commerce until today or last year
we sold 550 billion u.s dollars
from nothing to 550 billion dollars
and i think compared to yesterday was
big sales but compared to 10 years later
we are nothing
this is what i want to say the great
ideas i heard in the next
room inspired me and changed mine
you are guys at the hope of africa
and i believe 15 years ago 13 year
18 years in my apartment i told my team
we are the hope
of china because we are the guys without
any resources
if we can make it the most people can
make it
if most people like us without the money
with our resources only with the dream
and belief
if we can make succeed china will be
successful
i never thought it would be successful i
never thought
we could survive for 18 years
and then we made it the only thing that
today we should do is
share the experience and know how
especially share the mistakes
suffers with others my thinking is that
you guys remember if you want to be
successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make
don't listen to that there are a lot of
reasons behind it
just like um i remember the first time
harvard business school came to us
say jack we want to write a case study
for you
yes yes 2001 or 2000.
they came they spent one week and they
write a report and i read no
i said this is not me and this is this
is you
no this is not us he said this is you so
the makeup is signed
and the case study go up and they
started teaching a lot of universities
the next five years they invited me to
go to the case study
and they always find a competitor of my
company
and after every case study
alibaba will die that company will
succeed
all the students agree and actually
every five years all the competitors die
we still survive
so how can you study this kind of a
successful story
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are
you will encounter these mistakes
you learn from mistakes not because you
will be able to avoid mistakes
you were able to when these mistakes
come this suffer comes
you know how to deal with it
how to face it i
i the book i want to write if i
if i want if i can
it's alibaba 1001 mistakes
this is the most treasurable when you do
business
don't worry about competition there's
nowhere in this
world there's no competition you have to
get used to it
you cannot stop globalization the world
is getting so small
if you cannot stop it improve it
forget about the competition today it's
like a
10 000 meters running for the first
200 meters don't think that guy is
competitor keep on running
3000 meters later you will know who's
competitor
spending time on your customers spend
time
on your people on your own team don't
spend time
on your investors don't spend time on
your competitors
when you look at the people you want to
surf we look at the people you work
together
if they're happy you will win that's
very simple
[Music]
foreign
the only purpose of time we survived
we've 19 people 18 people gather 50 000
us dollars
we think we can last for about 10 miles
and then raise money
but only four months later no matter how
we tied the budget we still run off the
money
so everything we think about is to
survive but we believe
that internet will change china
independent would change the world
we believe if we don't succeed somebody
will
but if we start to do now
and be smart enough find the right
people
do the right things we will win but
later now uh that we're getting bigger
and bigger we
now think it's our responsibility
it's something that it's amazing
somebody put in our heart that we should
do more
because we find we helped created
40 million jobs we helped over millions
of
companies small companies survive why we
cannot help
100 million jobs globally why we cannot
help small business
africa middle east developing countries
developing countries
make them successful by the way the
difference between
artificial intelligence ai
oh and people is that
machine never have dreams we have dreams
if you don't have dreams you will never
win with machines in the future
you should work to end to be helped
right so
[Applause]
in order to encourage my 8 17 founders
and all the people who join us i said
our competitors are very
strong at that time our competitor was
ebay
a lot of the ebay guys from
graduate from harvard we are people
graduate from the
note i don't even mention about
the university names well nobody but i
say
if we can win if we can succeed
80 percent of the young people in china
in the world can be successful
because we believe we work a lot of our
dreams
but they don't work hard a lot of work
hard but they don't have dreams
entrepreneurs should work
[Music]
foreign
the only thing is that as an
entrepreneur
that never you know build up a good team
and set the the a big vision
but mile stones and you know go
go on never give up you might have a lot
of problems
right you can see the problem you're
facing your competitor will face it too
yeah and you think you have a lot of
tough days but you're competitively
having much easier
you never know right so so you say that
the competition between you is not a com
is is the speed of solving the problems
in this
changeable world keep changing is the
best
way to keep step could be successful
there's no there's i remember year 2000
when i tried to raise my money i went to
a lot of uh
venture capitalists they say jack give
me the business plan i said don't have a
business plan
write something and look at the others
they have such a thick
business plan you know i spent a whole
week right on one piece of paper
and they said this is a business plan a
book
the book is about how to be successful
in you know doing their business in
e-commerce and international i say
how can they write a book china was not
even connected to the internet
[Applause]
we never change our dreams but we change
ourselves
we learn from the mistakes from the
others and ourselves and change and
become
successful in my heart i'm always
curious
i'm curious a lot of things and
i know when i start alibaba i know
this is not the thing i want to do
in all my life i want to go back to
teaching
so i think life is a shot you should
experience
all kinds of things i don't want to die
in my office i want to die on the
beaches
right we work hard and we spend the
money but you spend the money should i
spend money smart way
first i try to making sure
that this company is a vision driven
strategy company it's a vision driven
company
i hate that alibaba ipo and every day we
worry about next quarter the quarter
after next
and this is no good this is i hate about
that
i i'm happy to be on the ball
joining some board many years ago some
big multinational companies are joined
there and
when they make decisions they they hate
they worry about make decisions for the
future
everybody only care for next quarter and
they buy
company merge company just for next
quarter
so i hate that so i say the day when we
ipo
we have to be making sure that this
company in next
84 years should always be a vision
driven company
and the second is as a chairman i should
making sure
the company should have a healthy
culture
and great people so this is the second
job as a chairman i should have
and the third before i retire
as a chairman i retired the ceo five
years ago
before i retired the chairman of the ceo
i tried my best to build
a healthy ecosystem for this company
to survive so these are the three jobs
that i took as the chairman and i
learned how to do that job better
and when i talked to the investors i
said joe was scared and and
all the team of financial teams are
scared because
i said i'm not scared i remember
that 18 years ago joe and i went to
silicon valley we talked to over
30 venture capitalists we said we want
to be one of the top
internet companies in the world and the
vcs all the venture capitalists were
scared
they all said no forget about it so we
did not raise any money
the first the trip joe and i went and
since then i did not write
any business plan
and then um well it was brief
at that time alibaba.com ranking like us
a couple of hundred million names behind
so we want to be number top of 10 sites
everybody thought we were crazy the
second time i remember
15 years it's like uh year 2003 when we
just
break even we start to compete with ebay
joe and i went to uh
san francisco oh no los angeles
and i talked to many big pes
and when i talk about we will move to
c2c
we will go to the consumer market we'll
compete with ebay
the investors at that time were also
scared no no no you have no chance to
win ebay because
c2c market in china has no chance ebay
taken
already taken 90 of the market share
and three years ago when i when we
listed in
new york and i said we will raise a
little bit money 20 billion dollars
people thought it was a joke but now
i think we need more money more money
for the future
and i think compared to the future
alibaba
is still a baby if you say in the past
18 years we were amaze i think we are
amazing we were
so lucky with the one of the luckiest
country company in the world we are in a
wonderful industry internet and we are
in a wonderful country like
china where we got so many supports from
our
colleagues and great team and all the
the things so we're lucky
but this company would love will
the vision is to last 102 years
so we have another 84 years to go
and uh people say wow
102 years it's a great number but we
take it really seriously as
me founder and chairman i really take
this thing
very seriously so every plan
every year on the strategy meeting we'll
review
what we're going to do next 10 years
what the 10 years every every project
every big investment we do we think
about 10 years later
we think about five years later so we
have a three year plan
five year plan and ten years plan almost
every year we review so without that if
you only
if you talk about 100 102 years but
never care about
five year plan or ten year plan you
really do not believe what you're
talking about
and i'm i want to tell all the investors
we are very serious
about 102 year vision that we have
another 84
years to go so compared to the future
you know our
market cap of course i think i'm happy
about that but don't compare to the
others if you compare to amazon i'm not
happy about that
but if you compare to the future we are
still a small company a very young
company
at 18 years old we are growing to that
size
but we still a baby thinking inside
so what we want to do in the future we
want to be
the 21st century a globalized company
and i would say the first technology
revolution
had the business model called a factory
the second technology revolution called
uh there's a business model called
company so what will be
the data time the internet time in the
21st
century what be the best business model
for this century
we think about is something called like
a platform the business
so we are lucky 15 years ago of or
we start to move our company from a
normal
like a website to a platform like
and i think the other thing is that
whether you're a big company a great
company
not depends on what kind of opportunity
you catch
most of the companies in china they're
always waiting for opportunity
if there's a good opportunity to catch
it they become a good company when they
cannot they when they miss some
opportunities
they're gone in china a couple of years
ago there was a very popular saying that
uh lugoniu it on a phone call
with internet right if you have pig
right even if you
if you're lucky happened to be on the uh
the the
the you know the uh on the wind some
drill you will
fly a pig will fly but if the wind goes
the pig will die so i think
that it's not about what kind of
opportunities
you grasp it's about what kind of value
you create for the future
what kind of problems you solve for the
world the big problem you
solve the world the big company will be
the great
problem you solve the work for the world
the great company
you will be so alibaba think about
one thing that what kind of problems we
can solve for the world in next
10 20 years if we are if we we can
figure out
the problem in 10 20 years what are the
problems
then we start to prepare now then we'll
be big
so we think we are company in hangzhou
we're not a company in new york
we're not company in silicon valley
we're not a company in beijing shanghai
we're accompanying hangzhou as a council
company
the way we compete with the others is
that how
we judge for the future you know that's
the competition we have
so we believe the future like this and
we spend all the resources going that
and we believe this will be the world
problem if we can solve that problem
we'll be great that's the way we think
about
how we lead our future so
today e-commerce cloud computing
and you know whatever business we have
all designed it
but 10 years ago 15 years ago so people
say you're great today now
i think we're not great today we were
great 10 years ago
10 years ago we believe this thing will
happen 15 years ago
we believe this thing will happen eight
years ago we believe cloud computing
big data will come so we start to make
decisions
18 8 15 and 10 years ago
and then we put all the resources all
the talents
everything just to focus on so i said to
many and
uh the entrepreneurs
if if there are nine rabbits on the
ground
if you want to catch one red rabbit you
should not
change the rabbit you should change
yourself just stick to one rabbit
that's the way to do it so we had our
vision
10 15 years ago we know this is what we
want to go
and we do anything change ourselves to
be sure
that we catch that rabbit in my
apartment where we started 18 founders
and we aim high we have a dream we say
we want to make
become the top 10 internet companies or
websites
in the world guys at that time we are
ranking
several million names who is it what
will be number 10
or the top 10 of the world we want to
make this company last 102 years
and we don't know where is our pay next
month
well when you are poor if you have a
dreams you never feel poor
you know what we are doing so after
we never say we would be we will win
next year or we win tomorrow we say we
will win
in 10 20 years 19 years past
today we are the top 10 websites com
internet companies in the world the
african desert
africa green is that the ecosystem is
not controlled
by lions and elephants
the ecosystem is controlled by the
insects
in the mud last century the company the
bigger the better
so everybody want to be a big company
the powerful company this century
from now on a good company is more
important than a powerful company
when you compete with become i think in
past 20 years
we've been competing with any company
lots of companies in china
but i learned one thing no matter
how strong an elephant is if you're an
ant if you hide yourself well an
elephant cannot kill you you can kill
the elephant if you're in a better way
it's about your thinking
watching your channel
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
1999 we start there the business and
people ask why not a beijing shanghai
why
hangzhou i mean now hanzo is this hub of
entrepreneur and startups and tech but
back then
back then hanzo is nowhere and and i
think
at that time nokia was so good
at that time and i said guys where is
nokia
it's a thing that some small island
headquarters there
it's not where you are i don't see
it's where your heart is where your
vision is
so we said beijing they love soe
stayed on the business shanghai they
love multinational companies
ibm microsoft in brazil startup
entrepreneur forget it right so i said
if in beijing
we're nobody in shanghai we're nobody if
we go
back to hangzhou we're the only child of
the local family
tough days and mistakes and this is
what if you start to think now would be
good
so if you ask me when i was a boy i
never felt about that
finally ygl from shanghai i know that
you recently spent a hundred million 100
billion
rmb in deep tech research i just wonder
how you think of the future of deep tech
and how that's going to
influence humanity and creativity thank
you
i think technology as a company we
invest
100 uh billion imb which is like 150
right of 15 no yes
i think billion 15 billion u.s dollars
on researching for the high tech um
as a company i hope in the future we
gain our profit because our technology
not because of a size so
we have to invest in technology but i
don't like this kind of
there's a debate artificial intelligence
big data
is going to threaten the human beings i
think
artificial intelligence should support
human beings
the technology should always doing
something to enable people
instead of disabled people
when steam machine comes when cars comes
people hate it you know today we think
car is good
when the man the the the automobile when
first was designed
people hate especially this car this
horseman
right they destroy every cars they can
see
so i would say people like us
when we have the money we have the
results we have the young all the
excellent
young people through being more
connected is that genuinely yeah
of course consumption will make uh
without consumption definitely we're not
happy
right but if their consumption may not
be the
thing is that for me people like me
uh people say jack you are very rich but
i don't have time to spend money
and i know this money that does not
belong to me
when i have a 1 million 2 million it's
my money
but when you have 20 million problem
comes you think the u.s dollars because
the valley or
angry pond and the stock market is gonna
problem when you're over one billion
dollars
that is the responsibility because the
society trusted you
can manage the money better if you think
that is your money
you'll get into trouble this is what i
always believe
that's the how can a person have
you know 20 or maybe two billion dollars
no matter how hard are you how hard you
work
you should not get to 2 billion 20
billion the money people put on you is
the trust and credit you have
so you should spend the money better
than government you should spend money
better than the other people spending
money on the right places
so consumptions yes
and i can service industry let me tell
you one thing
the ai robots is going to kill a lot of
jobs
because in the future machine
but there will be we have to create more
than service industry
we are like a war room
we make decisions based on whose voice
is
louder right early days you know we
fight and
talk and then making sure everybody
speak up
right so this is also a way of
mobilizing an incentive
there are a lot of ways and different
people have a different weight
to send incentive so this how much time
i sleep
yeah i have a problem i mean uh i don't
i sleep uh
not very short but not good
and i don't eat a lot
[Music]
this is something that i was curious
um i don't eat a lot i'm a very pickle
on the food
and uh i don't know sometimes i would
love to see
what the things that make me work like
that
but for sure that if i suddenly give me
one month's vacation
i'll collapse
it's i think there'll be something in my
heart
maybe the mission at the beginning is a
mission of 18 people
today we have 65 000 people they all
believe the mission
so if i give up i can give up my
position but i should not give up the
mission
if i give up everybody say hey no so
and then especially to the alibaba at
this size
people continue to say
for this size the growth rate will be
tiny
or down so what's the 10 20 years
alibaba would look like
if you want to be stupid greater
or triple our size what's what what the
direction
how to do it so i spend a lot of time
thinking
a lot of time thinking and i love to
think
good thing is i have a good team now i
think
i do the talk they do the work i think
life is a journey you come to this world
is to enjoy the life to be happy and
healthy
so the day when you leave the world you
say i'm happy
my life my health in this life because
if you're not healthy you will never be
happy
so i believe happy and healthy are the
things the human being always looking
for
and i think next to 30 years because of
the technology
uh people the life sciences is going to
change a lot and people is going to live
longer but we can live longer does not
necessarily live healthier
so if you're not healthy how can be
happy if you live longer if you're not
happy
while you live there people like us we
are getting used to be criticized
we are getting used to be said no
people say no to you when people say yes
to you
we really appreciate because it's not
you know why people should say yes to
you you have to prove so
as the entrepreneur you have to get used
to be
challenged have to get used to being
said no by the other people
by the found by the investors by your
customers
by the people but this this is the
opportunity
when everybody believe it you have no
chance when only a few people believe it
you believe it you prove it that's your
chance i think
everybody can be successful if you
really try
try hard i started alibaba 1999 in my
apartment
i talked to the 18 founders that
one thing one of the things we want to
prove if jack mai and his team can be
successful
80 of the people in the world they can
be successful
because we don't have money we have
technology we don't have almost nothing
the only thing is that we believe in the
future and start to do
little by little male founded companies
while women receive just 1.46 billion
and
as 2017 showed it was a year of
sexual harassment scandals the gender
pay gap still exists and unfortunately
the list does go on so how do you think
we can move beyond
tokenistic gestures towards genuine
gender equality
yeah that is very interesting a few
years like
four years ago there is a journalist
came to our company
and when he leaves he asked me questions
why there are so many women in your
company
and i never realized we have so many
women in our company
anything wrong today we have a 49
percent
close 49 of the employees of our company
are women that's a lot for a high-tech
company
it's not on purpose with high women we
think they are great
in helping us to grow alibaba is an
e-commerce company e-commerce is a
service industry
to serve people better you have you
should have a surf hub service heart
we find that women doing much
better jobs than men and the second is
that last
century people compete with muscle
no not this century is not muscle is the
wisdom i want to do
education because i was a
trained to be a teacher i feel guilty
for only taught
school for six years i feel good about
that
so that's why i'm talking everywhere i
think myself
ceo chief education officer
try my best to communicate
so in a sec i think china education
system
people say a problem china education
is teaching is knowledge is so good
teaching we're the best one of the best
in the world
go to any universities chinese students
taking exams for the best in the
stanford i think
right they're pretty good they're very
good but the e
the cultivate the e the culture teamwork
these are terrible
yes so we got to put more efforts on
that
this is something i want to help and
second environment i worry about
the air pollution the water all these
things and
and so that's why i joined the nature
conservancy
and the other thing the infrastructure
of the philanthropy you know bill gates
tried to convince me and with warren
buffett years ago came to china
we should donate every money
and i asked them well
how old are you volunteers 80. i said
when i'm 80 i would donate my money
i'm only 40. what is my
what is my philanthropy china you go to
beijing
shanghai they're rich places but they
are only small part of china go to the
east
western part of china so many poor
terror policies
as a business guy created jobs build
more business
making sure people have jobs making sure
people have a life good conditions this
is the key
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're gonna do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
if you want some incredible motivation
from elon musk check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there what's your advice today
i think that probably
they shouldn't want to be you it i think
it sounds better than it is
okay